so at the time when they were making
live-action movies out of any dumb old
cartoon yeah I know as opposed to today
George of the jungle was the one that
everyone thought was gonna be the
biggest flop and who can blame them it's
not like there was a ton to go off of
with the original cartoon and the past
live-action films based on cartoons have
been so bad this clearly had no chance
but with an upbeat innocent sense of
humor and an upbeat innocent main
character as well as upbeat innocent
side characters Georgia the jungle is a
lot of fun
is it die hard hilarious no buzz as kids
movies go this has a lot of stuff about
that's pretty unique person and her
fiance are on an exposition into the
jungle at some point they get separated
and she comes across a wild man named
George played by Brendan Fraser this is
obviously a Tarzan knockoff but it has a
few other twists to it for example he
doesn't really have a pet dog like most
people has he has a pet elephant yet
strangely enough it still acts like a
dog and not only can he communicate with
the Apes but the Apes can communicate
with people in fact they're kind of
geniuses one of them voiced by John
Cleese verse' wants to show George the
human world and George wants to show her
the ape world and we find out that the
fiancee is actually a bad guy he has
this evil plan and oh it doesn't matter
and I don't mean that in an insulting
way I mean then the way that literally
the film doesn't care much Ethan
the narrator keeps interrupting that
it's all fake it's all a film and it's
here for jokes and yeah it sort of works
that way and it works well it's all has
its own kid-friendly unique sense of
humor and the devotion all the actors
have to being silly throughout the
entire thing but still totally committed
is actually kind of charming there's
something nice about the fact that it
knows it's a kids movie and it's gonna
have fun with it it's not gonna try be
badass and make the kids older no it's
just gonna try and be smart and for lack
of a better word cute it is a cute movie
and I think a lot of people forget that
you can do cute movies okay not
everything has to have a ton of
references or swear words or really
harsh action or these dark backstories
you know what sometimes you can just
have a fun dumb comedy that can actually
be smart in its
this and it can be child-friendly it's
kinda like if the Zucker Brothers or Mel
Brooks did a kid's ville it's the same
amount of effort except it's put into
something that's family-friendly now as
I said before not every joke works in
fact there's a lot that really die and
don't go anywhere and you sir say to
yourself yeah you can't cut that but
truly after you see about five other
jokes that do work in you kind of forget
about them and the actors as well as the
narrator are so good at carrying you
from one joke to another that it just
feels like fun you don't want to rate
every joke or judge the story or the
pacing or anything you just kind of sit
back and enjoy it and that's the kind of
experience I had I don't think it's a
big staple for comedy or anything but
for a movie that clearly should have
been dead on arrival it's actually very
enjoyable kids love it adults seem to
like it what's not to enjoy I mean aside
from the catchiest theme song that'll
never leave your head now scared I enjoy
that too George George George of the
jungle